Things are looking grim
for the presidential candidacy
of swollen Nicolas Cage
character Donald Trump.
(laughter)
He's responding
to dropping poll numbers
by softening his rhetoric
and taking a more reasoned,
compassionate tone
with his speeches.
Nah, I'm just (bleep) with you.
He's headed back
to the bat (bleep) buffet
for another heaping helping
of jingoistic nonsense.
Here he is talking about
his cool new immigration policy.
I call it "extreme vetting."
I call it extreme...
extreme vetting.
(laughter) -Wait.
I'm a little... I'm a little
unclear on that.
What kind of vetting was that?
Was that just normal,
run-of-the mill vetting,
or extreme?!
(applause and cheering)
-♪
-I call it extreme...
extreme vetting.
(applause and cheering)
Mm.
-That works? That works?
-Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
-The kids love heavy vetting.
-(laughter)
Now this totally bitching new
policy would require immigrants
to take an intense loyalty test
to prove that they're
as American as (bleep)
enough for Trump's U.S. of A.
I guess if this questionnaire
becomes a reality, what's
a question you think Trump
might put on it? Maz Jobrani.
He's gonna say, "I'm gonna do
some word association with you.
"I'm gonna give you a word.
"You say the first thing
that comes to your mind.
Allahu Akbar!"
(laughter)
-HARDWICK: All right.
-(applause and cheering)
Gina.
I think he's gonna ask
some hard questions,
see if he can catch you at it.
He'd be like, "What do you
prefer-- hot dogs and fireworks
on the Fourth of July,
or September the 11th?!"
(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-Ah, oh. Ah, oh. Oh, no!
Jon Dore.
He'd probably say,
"Are you a rapist?
-I mean, Mexican?"
-(laughter)